qué opinas de que se declare
que todos los animales sean sintientes
que pasa con la carne
el consumo de la carne
al aprobarse la nueva constitución
va a tener que ser erradicado
nunca más vamos a poder comer asados
de vacuno de cerdo
de pollo desde ahora las vacas
los cerdos
y los pollos van a ser animales sagrados
igual que en la india
no podremos volver a consumir su carne
yo voy a dejar de hacer
la sección de los completos
porque lamentablemente
los completos italianos
ahora van a venir con vienesa vegetal
tampoco vamos a poder ir al burger king
ni al mcdonald's
porque las hamburguesas van a ser vegetales
de soya además
al aprobarse la nueva constitución
se establece
que no podremos matar otro tipo de animales
las hormigas son animales
por lo tanto de ahora en adelante
cuando vayamos a un parque
tenemos que ir con extremo cuidado
de no pisar ningún tipo de hormiga
no conformes con eso
estos comunistas además nos van a exigir
al aprobarse la nueva constitución
que todos los días a las 3 de la tarde
tenemos que sagradamente venerar a los gatos
y por último no conformes con estos
estos comunistas
chavistas bolivarianos
seguramente le están haciendo caso a la onu
vamos a tener que todos
obligatoriamente adoptar un perro quiltro
se nos vienen tiempos muy difíciles gente